looks like a nightclub out there with
those ropes how are you good to see you
there's a lot of red Wow I'm Christo's
Christo's should have shaved and what
you do here lifestyle concierge down
here at the front desk you advise I mean
for my life are you gonna be you mean
dinner reservations they organize
everything
anything you need huh now somebody likes
red is that smudged it likes red or no
it's both the designer in the owner Wow
well we're on the second floor second
floor please perfect thank you right
here I like to always stop with the car
which floor has a different model car
who's obsessed with the supercars who is
that the owner every so right here this
is your room Wow yes it's so empty more
like a gown in the guest room and how
much is this a nice seven fifty nine
seven hundred and fifty nine dollars wow
that's incredibly expensive
what's that thing there that is actually
the jacuzzi tub in the middle of the
lounge it is in the lounge Wow
design the rooms they took away all the
interior walls but without sounding
stupid these are car designers correct
they are car design now they've put in
jacuzzis in the middle of suite last
time I checked a living room was for
sitting in not taking a bath how much do
these things cost the jacuzzi tub itself
is about 20,000 knives if you don't take
baths oh this is crazy
oh who wanted all these specially design
that is their own area that's that's
Eddie yes this is crazy oh [ __ ] the
sports car inspired furniture looks
cheap and isn't even functional it's
different than anything else different
from a nice hotel room I don't know
about that who doesn't want to sit here
and sort of watch the television and
watch the television it works though
the sheets how can also wrinkle well
have you accept in there why is that we
do them in house we say we would you
mean you don't do laundry lifestyle
means everything your mouthwash it's
like gas sock is all broken and smashed
down there and someone's left that dirty
ones there the plastic plants
that's outrageous $100 oh my gosh Gordon
doesn't like anything about the hotel
damn it
anything else if I have any lifestyle
needs I'll call thank you
of course so far I'm not impressed with
the Keating's pretentious and
uncomfortable design but maybe it can
redeem itself with the one thing every
luxury hotel should have impeccable room
service I'm starving
come on your desk this is Christo's how
many of us is gone what's a little bit
bizarre for me as I'm ordering room
service
there's no direct line down to the
kitchen there is no direct line down to
the kitchen the communication between
the apartments is and they look really
there so we make sure it happens
listen I'm starving I'm out of tomato
soup please and then pizza and barbecue
chicken I'm fascinated to see the
chicken parmesan sliders I have one of
those as soon as I can put it okay thank
you
hello hello thank you
is this how it's normally served in a
to-go box yes you pay $100 a night to
stay here and you got to eat your food
out of boxes and plastic containers are
we short of soup it's not even half full
that's not they serve it that much yes
it's one cup it's like a retirement home
is that luxury do you think yeah not at
all what would you rather do sip that
out of a cup of course we barely got
half a cup anyway I love digging if
there's anything else I can do for you
just go ahead and let us okay
burn aids mm-hmm darling I'm sorry you
say that now it's finished thank you my
pleasure a chicken parmesan slider
that's dreadful
now I know why they got the boxes is to
take away poop box
Pizza unappetizing in a box especially
when you're spending $100 a night
this place is obsessed with design but
sirs room service in Ploesti containers
no wonder they can't fill the ruse that
is not my idea of luxury let me tell you
that's embarrassing
Wow
[Music]
how can this place call itself a luxury
hotel I need to get some answers from
Eddie the Keating's owner and visionary
hey how are you ABC this place has been
your baby in many ways and I'm dying to
find out the vision the insight and to
why give us a little talk I bought the
building back in 2000 I was around six
million did you go to hotel school no
you've never run a business before
no no tell business no well so it's
actually I had the Ferrari dealer
looking at cars and stuff and it kind of
hit me why not the Ferrari of hotels I'm
walking somewhat you were smoking at the
time and what you're thinking why would
you take one of those high spec cars
anywhere in the world and turn it into a
hotel I don't know where he's coming
from but it does piss me off
I designed the keating to be the perfect
hotel for me not for him West I start
the floor it's all scuffed and marked
you have a resin floor needs to be
updated
I mean everything's just marked to hell
it feels cheap and the sheets you can't
call yourself a luxury hotel if you
don't have beautifully pressed sheets
what's the idea behind sitting here so
when you have guests you know we could
sit down and talk on it but where's our
sofa where's the table
where's our fun you know what I heard
the most I got soup served in a plastic
bowl but it's a chicken parmesan slider
that tasted like it was cooked three
days ago who in the [ __ ] would put a
chicken parmesan slider together there's
things that don't go in sliders and
chicken parm is one of them that was my
idea
B laughing as if it's funny and you
think because you own the place you can
put that in a roll and sell it I don't
know what he's talking about it this
place is not bad so I think Gordon's
comments would complete [ __ ] you're
trying to convince me this is your idea
of luxury I don't know the simple one is
that's how you stayed in the hotel too
in a while you cannot stand there and
tell me that there's nothing wrong with
this place when you don't even stay in
it
he bought a building that was your dream
but it doesn't feel like a dream
experience to a guest
no we're [ __ ] near it